-We're hanging out with our
good pal, Matthew McConaughey,
who stars in the new film
"Sing 2."
What a cast in "Sing 2."
-Isn't it?
-Well, it's just you,
Scarlett Johansson,
Reese Witherspoon,
and then -- no big deal --
you add Bono to the mix.
-Bono shows up.
-Yeah, no big deal.
-Thank you, Bono.
-It's always
a party when Bono shows up.
-It is always a party
when Bono shows up.
-Yeah. I mean, it's an amazing
part of the movie, as well.
I loved the first "Sing."
My kids loved it, as well.
But "Sing 2," another hopeful
movie, makes you laugh.
It makes you want to
sing, obviously.
But the stakes are
higher in this one.
-Stakes are higher in this one.
We pulled off the show in
"Sing 1" in our town.
Now we're taking it to
Redshore City,
which is, in our movie, Vegas,
the biggest stage on the planet.
And -- whew! --
are we going to pull it off?
How can we pull it off?
I, as Buster Moon,
who's got to put the show on,
write a lot of checks
that I can't cash,
make a lot of promises
I don't know if I can keep.
But with the help of a lot of
my team in the show --
You go see it,
see if we pulled it off.
-It's so cute. It's so funny.
-The movie is -- it's good news.
We need some good news
right now.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Exactly right.
-It's about chasing the dream
but also, how do you get it?
The hustle you got to have,
the dealing with the rejection,
which is part of it,
all the doubt,
but can you believe your way
through the doubt?
-Yep.
-You know? And it's fun.
There's something
for everyone to sing.
-It's your kids.
You're the parents.
It's your grandparents.
You can all sing along
in this one.
-By the way,
the soundtrack on this one --
I don't know how you
pulled it off.
Are we allowed to even say
the names or we don't know?
-I think we can.
-Can we say BTS, Prince,
Cardi B.
-Yeah.
-And, obviously, U2.
-Yeah. New song.
U2 has got a new song you
never heard before
and the classics off of
"Joshua Tree."
-I mean --
-No, no, no, it's thick.
It is thick.
-I remember,
I was walking around New York,
and I got one of those --
This is back when
I was on "SNL."
I got just a radio, just, like,
a Sony radio, like, a Walkman.
No tape,
just to listen to radio,
because when you are in
New York, you just walk around.
There's no -- And, you know,
I just want to listen to music.
And "Where the Streets
Have No Name" came on,
and I just go --
And it was like,
"I want to run."
And I just started running.
I just ran until
I hit the water.
Yeah. I just loved it.
I go -- It just felt right.
I go, "That's what Bono
would want me to do."
He'd want me to just
take off -- right? --
and keep running, man.
-That's exactly what
he wanted you to do.
-Exactly what -- And I did it.
Then I had to walk all the way
back with a different song.
I can't control the radio.
I know your daughter got to do
a little part in this film.
-She did.
-That's so cute.
-Vida got a couple of lines
in "Sing 2."
She plays a piglet who
is scuba-diving in chocolate.
-Yeah! Come on!
-Saying, "This is
the best day of my life."
-I mean, it is the best day if
you get to scuba-dive
in chocolate.
-How about that?
-I mean, it's the most fun.
And I got to tell everybody.
It's just so -- And Nick Kroll.
-Nick Kroll.
"I'm fine. How are you?"
-Gunter, I mean --
-Gunter, oh!
-Anyways, it's great.
The whole family
should go check it out.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Matthew McConaughey
in "Sing 2."
Take a look at this.
-Miss Crawly, it's me, Mr. Moon.
I haven't heard from you
in a while.
I'm starting to worry here.
-Moon!
-[ Gasps ]
-Mr. Crystal.
-Your set designs
are a disgrace!
-What?!
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
I'm just messing with you.
Where is your
sense of humor, huh?
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyway, this is
my daughter, Porsha.
-Hey!
-Nice to meet you, Porsha.
-She wants to meet Calloway.
Big fan, aren't you, baby?
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm, like,
so into vintage right now.
-So, where is he?
-Uh, well, I'm -- I'm not
expecting Clay on set just yet.
I mean --
-Wait.
Is this like a sky-fi show?
-Uh, sci-fi?
Yes. Yes, it is.
-Oh, my gosh!
I love sky-fi.
-Oh, it's a "ski-fi."
-I love "ski-fi," too!
Matthew McConaughey, everybody!
"Sing 2" opens in theaters
December 22nd.